so let me ask about nietzsche
is god dead
what do you mean by that statement yeah
what's in your sons the truth behind the
question
and the possible set of answers that our
world today provides
good so i i mean i i think that
there's something super perceptive about
nietzsche's diagnosis of the condition
at the end of the 19th century
so not so far from the condition that i
think we're currently in
and i think there's an interesting
question what we're supposed to respond
what we're supposed to do in response
but what what is the condition that
we're currently in when nietzsche says
god is dead
i think like i was saying before he he
means something like the role that god
used to play in grounding our existence
is not a role that works for us anymore
as a culture
and when people talk about a view like
that nowadays
they use a different terminology but i
think it's roughly what nietzsche was
aiming at
they say we live in a secular age
our age is a secular age and so what
what do people mean when they say that
i think
first of all it's a descriptive claim it
could be wrong
the question is does this really
describe the way we experience ourselves
as a culture or as a culture in the west
or wherever it is that we are
so what does it mean to say that we live
in a secular age an age in which god is
dead well it first thing is it doesn't
mean there are no religious believers
because there are plenty there are lots
of people who
go to church or synagogue or mosque you
know every week or more and there are
people who
really find that to be an important
aspect of the way they live their lives
but
it does mean
that for those people
the role of their religion the role that
the religious their religious belief
plays in their life isn't the same as it
used to be in previous ages so what's
that role
we'll go back to the high middle ages
that was clearly not a secular age
that was a religious age
and so there we are in 1300 dante is
writing the divine comedy or something
and what did it what did it mean then to
live in a sacred age well it meant
not just that
the default was that you were were a
christian in the west
but that your christianity your
religious belief your religious
affiliation
justified certain
assumptions about people who didn't
share that religious belief so you're a
christian
in the west in 1300 and you meet someone
who's a muslim
and the fact that they don't share your
religious belief
justifies the conclusion that they're
less than human
and that's that was the ground of the
you know the crusades that was the
religious wars of the high middle ages
we live in it to say that we live in a
secular age is to say that
not that we don't have there aren't a
lot of people who have religious belief
there are but it's to say that their
religious belief ju doesn't justify that
conclusion
if
you're a religious
believer and you meet me and suppose i'm
not a religious believer
learning that about me doesn't justify
your concluding that i'm less than human
right and that's the kind of liberalism
of the of the modern age most of the
time we think that's a good thing we let
a thousand flowers bloom there are lots
of ways to live a good life
and there's some way in which that that
is a nice progressive kind of liberal
thought
but it's also true that it's an
undermining thought because
it means
if you're a religious believer now
your belief can't ground your
understanding of what you ought to be
aiming at in the life
in the way it used to be able to you
can't say
as a religious believer i know it's
right to do this because you also know
that if you meet someone who doesn't
share that religious belief and so
doesn't think it's right to do that
necessarily or does but for different
reasons
you you can't conclude that they've got
it wrong right so there's this sort of
unsettling aspect to it well isn't it
true that uh you you can't conclude as a
as a public statement to others but
within your own mind
it's almost like an existentialist
version of uh belief which is like it's
you create the world and
around you like it doesn't matter what
others believe
you don't
there's not it's actually almost like um
empowering thought so as opposed to the
more
traditional view of religion
where it's like a tribal idea like where
you share the idea together here you
have the full
back disartry a full responsibility of
your beliefs as well
good good but what you're describing
is not a religious believer right you're
describing someone who's
found in themselves the ground of their
existence rather than in something
outside of themselves so the religious
belief i mean if you go full sartrian
then
uh well you're not in a position to
criticize others for the choices that
they make
but you are in a position to criticize
them for the way in which they make them
either taking responsibility or not
taking responsibility but the but the
religious believer used to be able to
say look the choices that i make are
right because god demands that i make
them
and nowadays
like
and so it would be wrong to make any
others
and nowadays
are kind of
to say that we live in a secular age say
well you you can't quite can't quite do
that and be a religious believer your
religious belief can't
can't justify that move and so it can't
ground
your life in the way it does so it's
sort of unsettling i think that's one of
the interpretations of what nietzsche
might have meant when he said god is
dead god can't play the role for
religious believers in our world that he
used to
but we nevertheless find meaning i mean
you don't see
nihilism as a prevalent set of ideas
that are overtaken modern culture so a
secular world is still full of meaning
good well i think that's the interesting
question i i think i think it's
certainly possible for a secular world
to be a world in which we live
meaningful lives worthwhile lives lives
that uh
are
sort of um worthy of respect and that we
can be proud of of aiming to live
but but i think it is a hard question
what we're doing when we do that and
that's the that is the question of
existence sort of what does it mean
to exist in a way that brings us out at
our best as the beings that we are
that's the question for existentialism
you